la réunion est en deuil parce que paul
vergès aura marqué incontestablement
l'histoire de la réunion et j'ai envie
de dire aussi l'histoire de la
départementalisation on perd un grand
combattant
celui qui a porté sur les fonts
baptismaux le parti communiste
réunionnais le père de la
départementalisation mais aussi l'homme
qui a été un grand un grand visionnaire
un grand bâtisseur de la réunion
bâtisseurs parce que c'est le père de la
compagnie régionale également avec
pialat mourgues c'est le père de la
route des tamarins c'est celui qui a
porté deux grands chantiers le
visionnaire le premier à avoir parlé des
effets des changements climatiques sur
l'environnement et sur la société
aujourd'hui on a de la peine on pense à
toute la famille à pierre aux enfants ou
petits-enfants à françoise et nous leur
adressons toutes nos condoléances et
notre sympathie